there's a lot that will be happening
this summer
well it happened katy perry is
officially a mom
this is my favorite honor so far the 35
year old singer gave birth to her first
child with fiance orlando bloom
a baby girl the american idol judge
first revealed her pregnancy in march
when she dropped her music video
for never worn white
[Music]
after perry announced her pregnancy she
took to twitter joking
omg so glad i don't have to suck it in
anymore or
carry around a big purse in april the
fireworks singer posted this adorable
photo of bloom
covered in pink frosting captioning it
with it's a girl
shortly before the gender reveal perry
told fans that she was hoping for a baby
girl
during a concert on international
women's day in australia
throughout her pregnancy perry kept fans
updated on everything from how she was
feeling
to her cravings i like literally
never cared for spice and now
i have to carry tabasco sauce in my
purse like that woman
like i am that woman i am karen with her
tabasco sauce
in may she also gave fans a glimpse at
her bear baby
bump in the music video for her song
daisies
during katie's pregnancy a source told
et she was quote
over the moon as starting a family has
always been a dream for her
adding katie's priority has always been
a lifetime partner and building a family
and future together
perry and bloom first met in 2016 and
later got engaged on valentine's day in
2019.
in march a source told et that the power
couple are postponing their nuptials
they had planned in japan this year
due to the worldwide coronavirus
outbreak and they will tie the knot
in 2021. in the meantime the two have
their hands full with their baby girl
and thanks to quarantine the new mom
told et she's had a lot of time to prep
i'm surrounded by many uh mothers with
my sister
and my brother's wife and my mom i mean
we've all been
quarantining together for eight weeks
and
you know we had my brother's nephew in
with us for seven weeks and he's only
eight months and then i have a
three-year-old and a six-year-old niece
and then flynn orlando's son who's
you know basically a stepson he's nine
years old so
i'm getting the full range of ages and
needs before giving birth perry was
balancing her role as a judge on
american idol
and once she returns it will be a family
affair
i mean honestly i'll be i'll be feeding
from the booth
oh my god get used to it
this is gonna turn into a real family
[Music]
show